cast IRL will be live in Miami with
Patrick Bet David Donald Trump Jr Matt
Gates and Luke gradkowski join us there
get your tickets by clicking the link in
the description below or by going to
timcast.com Let's jump into that news
from the post-millennial federal judge
blocks New Mexico Governor's firearm
carry ban amazing on Wednesday a federal
judge blocked New Mexico Governor
Michelle at Luan grisham's temporary
band of the carrying of firearms in the
state with high crime rates U.S District
Judge David Urias issued a temporary
restraining order following a hearing
spurred on by a series of civil lawsuits
filed against the governor by pro-gun
activist groups who argued the ban
infringed on citizens constitutional
rights as Reuters reports Uriah is sided
with opponents of the move agreeing that
it went against the rights of
law-abiding citizens to carry firearms
for self-defense and recent Supreme
Court rulings on the issue they just
want the right to carry guns he said in
the days since Grisham signed the
executive order she has faced criticism
from within New Mexico and across the
country and especially they're going to
mention that the AEG of New Mexico said
that he would not defend the governor
that means when it came to these
lawsuits she can be standing up there by
herself being like I should be allowed
to do this and the judge's gonna be like
yeah sorry no you have no legal
arguments and you lose so let me just
stress once again while there are
concerns about our gun rights while we
do need to repeal the NFA and abolish
the ATF that does not mean we are losing
in fact we are winning and for decades
we have expanded the right to keep and
bury arms uh keeping Barry keep and
carry to bear and keep oh man I'm all
over the place uh We've expanded the
rights to uh bear arms to carry to
possess and people need to understand
that you go back before 2008 it was
still very difficult so Victory upon
Victory the move made by this governor
was the was a death throw it was pure
desperation and even after she did it a
bunch of dudes showed up in Albuquerque
and we're like nah and they showed up
armed they're losing they know they're
losing and here's the best part about it
it forced people like David Hogg and Ted
Lou to come out and be alike we actually
oppose the the Banning of Guns by decree
here's the best part beyond that
when they started shutting everything
down over kovid saying that public
health trumped to the Constitution this
has forced them backwards and now you've
got personalities like David Hogg saying
there is no Public Health exception to
the Constitution so we've forced their
position back past the Line This is
Victory this is when you're talking
about winning this is something that's
been on I think heard you guys talking
about it last night trying to describe
it because like okay say you have 10
victory points and there's two teams
each team needs all 10 points to win one
of the teams has eight of them and your
team has two you would say you're losing
but then if you win a great battle and
they all their their troops are gone now
they're they're fleeing backwards and
now you can go and you're about to take
all all eight of those victory points
because they have no defense you might
still technically be losing because you
only control two of the victory points
but the momentum is shifted I I and that
you could consider winning as a form of
momentum and positioning and and here's
another analogy you're playing dodgeball
and you have five players on one side
and five on the other
for the first two thirds of the game
they've knocked out four of your players
and so there's one person left and it's
like man we are losing then all of a
sudden the dude picks up the ball they
throw it he bounces it back hits one of
their guys knocks them out they whip one
he catches it another player's back in
within a few minutes it's now
three players on your team three players
on their team and you may be saying
they've got so much power but now
they're starting to to trip they're
stumbling over themselves they're in
panic they're in disarray you have
picked up the momentum because you have
begun to win the momentum has changed
this this New Mexico gun ban attempt is
exactly what I thought should happen in
a just Society is that a governor makes
a tyrannical move the people come out
they protest and then even the Attorney
General refuses to work with the Tyrant
and that's it's very encouraging but
I've always got to uh tell people it
always depends on what your players do
once momentum shifts because you're one
mistake away from ending up you know
back where you started and so it's kind
of like right now we're seeing that hey
the public still does not have a stomach
for government overreach that's amazing
but the problem is this is sort of
conditioning the Overton window I know
you guys saw the whole news with uh UNC
Chapel Hill with the shooting or not the
almost shooting the dangerous individual
right well that right there happened
literally a day after apparently the
March for our lives was in the
courthouse shout or not the courthouse
the legislature shouting down their
people so if you get something like that
how that just gives them a nice little
barometer for how much fear they need in
order to condition people there's
good go ahead good well it's just we
know that we know that our government
uses assets we know that again the CIA
the FBI groups like that they entrap
people they cause situations where
people end up getting a gun somehow
miraculously and then going on a spree
and so I just always wonder
are they going to use this to
recalibrate who can who you know who
knows how well they calibrate anything
actually and that's what people need to
understand for next year I am not
concerned about a false flag where a CIA
or FBI guy or whatever claims to be a
trump supporter in a moga hat and then
goes and commits some ACT what they do
every single time and this is not a
conspiracy theory but the media will lie
anyway the FBI sends criminal informants
and agents to convince people to commit
acts of violence that way they can be
like there he is there's your proof they
Supply the individuals they give them
the opportunity they give them the ideas
they set them up and then say Oh
Heaven's me look what they're doing
what you need to be careful of is when
they start to trick you with fed talk
like Ray Epps yelling to go in the
capital and everyone started chanting
fed yes when you're seeing their plans
fail when you're seeing liberals forced
to say you can't have a public health
exception to the Constitution after
kovid wow we won that okay I gotta say
like we won that one if if Democrats are
coming out now saying you cannot
overrule the Constitution with with a
public health order but three years ago
they literally claimed you could we've
won that battle this is I mean this is
definitely a white pill um overall the
response from the rest of the the
country
you know people outside of of New Mexico
I think is is probably the the thing
that I is most impactful to me
um I don't personally trust uh Ted Lou
or David Hogg to actually have much of a
stomach for
um supporting individual rights and
stuff like that honestly
um but at the same time the fact that
they spoke up was good the fact that the
AG won't defend her is very very good
the fact that the mayor was like you
know against it as well that's very very
good
um Firearms policy Coalition the uh
they're they're on X there at gun policy
and you should definitely follow him you
should probably become a member as well
um they did a really good job of of live
tweeting it today and inside the
courtroom the the the judge just didn't
have much patience for the argument
being beloved arguments being made by
the the state you know the the fact is
the Bruin case is essentially a nuclear
weapon when it comes to the right to
keeping bear arms Bruin found that you
know you have the right to keep and bear
you can keep it on you and carry it with
you and it's not a second class right
the way that legislatures or I'm sorry
uh the way that that uh administrations
had treated the Second Amendment up
until Bruin is that it wasn't actually a
right it was a privilege and the Bruin
case has made it clear that that is not
acceptable and this the judge today
specifically said that Bruin has made it
clear that we do not have the right to
interpret the law the law is as it says
that the the right to keep in bear arms
isn't going to be infringed it's outside
of the purview of the federal of the of
the Federal and consequently the state
governments because the Constitution is
the supreme law of the land so it's
outside of the purview of any government
to say you can't you can't have a gun to
carry on you barring a uh you know due
process I uh I think the next Victory we
need to make is
I don't know how we do it because it's
going to require the Supreme Court but I
will I have no problem saying this
I have no legal experience none
did not go to law school I've only been
in court a handful of times and the
Supreme Court Justices are wrong on on
the ability of a state to require a
permit
the right shall not be infringed if I am
required to pay money
in order to get permission from the
government permission permit then
they've infringed my rights yeah and the
Supreme and this was this is Kavanaugh
who said well they can require permits
but they can't use it as a shield and to
manipulate basically what was happening
was these states were saying yes you can
get a gun just felt this permit and they
crumpled up and throw in the garbage
they're using it as a way to block you
from getting guns I said no if you take
the the form you have to issue the
permit they're still trying to find
loopholes New Jersey's loophole was uh
you had to have uh you have to have
proof of some kind of threat and you
have to have a reason why the threat
exists so it's like you have to be rich
or famous basically so wouldn't this so
be kind of where they try to use the
elastic clause and you know they start
to really sort of massage the the
firmness of the rule of shall not be
infringed and what a well-regulated
means because we've seen them play fast
and loose with terms and definitions in
the past we've seen them do this and say
oh no well-regulated means you've got to
have these many stipulations on it and
you can only have this and you know they
weren't talking about these ppus they
were talking about these pupus and it's
just kind of like this new School of Law
and interpretation of law that we have
going is set up to where people can take
dubious and you know sort of nebulous
language and twist it into how they want
it and that's what's coming out of law
schools now are lawyers that love to
play fast and loose with definitions in
their what the Constitution and you know
what the people back in the day would
call loose constructionists there was
actually a judge who refused to rule on
what a woman was saying and because the
argument was that in today's context
women could mean many different things
no there was a reason we passed a law
and how we describe it doesn't matter
because we know what the law is
intending to do to simplify we did not
create women's volleyball because
sometimes people wear dresses we did it
because men and women are different
so when we said women's sports we didn't
mean if you're wearing a dress or you're
wearing pants volleyball but this is the
game they're playing when they say well
if someone says they're when they are
therefore women sports no no no no then
let's change it to female and male
Sports I this is something that we've
talked about a little bit
um in the past here
the use of language like that to change
the use of changing the uh the meanings
of words essentially means that you have
changed the meaning of laws yeah right
without actually having any kind of
whether it be a vote or your
representatives don't you know don't
present it to the legislature or
anything like that and that's a way that
people that are looking to infringe on
your rights or possibly take your
property this is something that James
Lindsay brings up
all of the uh the dedications of land to
uh First Nations or whatever that kind
of stuff
it's a bad thing because if you can
convince people that you are on Stolen
land then you do not have legitimate
ownership of that land that means they
can just take it is your your property
used to be on uh on you know the
whatever the whatever First Nation uh
group or whatever oh that's not yours
we're taking your house remember that's
the I that's the goal is to remove
property rights because if the
government is restricted by the law from
taking your property without due process
that limits their that limits the power
that they have there is nothing that the
left wants more than to have absolute
power to be able to take your property
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time